The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: So last week
was the intro class and then
the human power lab.
Today, I just told
you what we're doing.
On Friday, we'll have
the energy storage lab,
and then next week
into lighting.
And in two weeks is Quiz 1, just
so you have it in your minds.
So the Muddy Cards.
We're going to do
this one at the end.
So there were some
questions on the estimation.
So one was what if I have no
reference point for estimation?
For example, I have no idea
what a D cell is, basically.
So then, you're stuck.
Because it's really
hard, if I ask
you to estimate the power
in a glob, and you're like,
what's the glob, Amy?
And I'm not telling you,
because it's an estimation,
you're stuck.
And so if I literally say
glob, and you're like,
I have no idea what a
glob is, then you're done,
and you have to
reference some of manual.
But if you know D
cell is a battery,
then the best practice
is to say, OK,
am I familiar with
any battery, say
a double A or a car battery
or a 9-volt or something?
And say I'm going to--
just write an explicit
assumption in your estimation.
I'm assuming a D
cell is a 9-volt,
or a D cell is a car
battery, or whatever
assumption you make that
brings you to something
you're familiar with.
And that way, when
you do the estimation,
and if you do it
clearly, then when
you have time to
check that assumption,
you can then very quickly
revise your estimate
based on real-world data.
And that way, if it's something
you're turning into me,
or it's something you're
using in the real world,
you still get to do something.
And maybe you'll
have less confidence
in that answer at the end.
So maybe you're going to be
off by a couple of orders
of magnitude rather than one.
But at least you've
done something
rather than just sat
there looking bored.
But if I say glob, and
you literally are like,
I have no idea what
you're talking about,
then yeah, that's
a tricky situation.
But hopefully, that
doesn't come up too often.
Yeah, Kirk?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] do
you want us to kind of pull
a number out of thin air for
something like how much energy,
like solar-thermal system--
AMY BANZAERT: So that wasn't
an explicit estimation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMY BANZAERT: So that
would be a case where
you should be googling
and documenting
where you get your numbers but,
absolutely, looking stuff up.
Generally, I will say
estimate, if I mean estimate.
But if you're
unclear, always ask.
I'm not 100% responding to
email quickly, but I try to.
And if you don't hear
from me in 24 hours,
just send another
email, and be like,
seriously, give me the answer.
I get a lot of emails per
day, as I'm sure we all do,
and sometimes it hurts.
If you put an explicit D-Lab
Energy in the subject line,
that will probably improve my
ability to respond quickly.
Because I won't necessarily
recognize your email,
but I will see that a subject.
So yeah, but I my intention
is to respond quickly,
but I got people like emailing
me at 1:00 in the morning,
needing a response
by the next morning.
And that is hard for me, if
I've already gone to bed.
Sometimes, I haven't,
but if I have,
I usually don't get
to email until midday.
So that's just a warning that,
unfortunately, or fortunately,
I don't keep 2:00
AM hours anymore.
Usually, I try not to.
Another one was a situation
where we could actually use
estimates in the real world.
And I hope that will become
clear as the weeks go on.
But for example, your
community partner
may well say let's put
a wind turbine here.
Could we do wind power here?
And literally, that
will be the question.
And your choice is to say,
I have no idea or yes or no.
Or give me 10 minutes,
let me do an estimation,
and then you can give a
much more useful answer
than any of those.
And so you could
very quickly say,
well, talk to me
about wind speed,
and we'll talk about how to
estimate wind power later
on in the semester.
But so how much of
the branch is moving?
Are you falling down
because of the wind,
or is it just a little
breeze occasionally?
And get an estimate
of the wind speed,
and then you can run
through a calculation that
says, yes or no, you
could power a light bulb
or whatever you want.
And those questions
come up all the time.
Or I really want to
do solar power, how
much is it going to cost me?
And being able to give
someone a ballpark
by running through the numbers
really quickly is great.
Or when you're in
a job interview,
and someone asks you these
sorts of questions, probably,
not necessarily, about
developing-country stuff,
but just a random question.
Having that skill will
serve you in a job interview
when you're in a consulting
job, and a customer asks you
a question, when you're
in developing countries.
It's going to be
useful, I swear.
And it's pretty powerful
to be able to answer,
instead of just being
like, I don't know.
I wish I did.
So I screwed up and mentioned
that the LED was in amp hours,
and I sent you guys all an
email apologizing for that.
So amp hours would be how
long a battery can last,
and there was a
confusion about that.
So for example, if a battery
has a 2-amp-hour rating,
for example, which
is kind of low,
and you know voltage
of your battery,
or the voltage
that you're using,
and the current
that you're drawing.
Then you can use the
current to figure out,
so let's say it's 2
milliamps is your current,
then you can divide
the 2 amp hours.
Divide it by 2
milliamps equals 1--
I really fail at
math on the board.
Am I blocking in the camera?
Sorry.
So we have 1,000 hours
that is going to last,
and again, you have efficiency
issues with batteries
that we'll talk about
a little bit today.
So that's not an
exact number that you
can rely on, that
my battery is going
to last exactly 1,000 hours.
But it gives you, again, an
order of magnitude estimate.
Yeah.
So does anyone have a question
about amp hours versus amps?
Batteries?
Some of these Muddy
Card questions,
please keep putting questions
you have on the Muddy Cards.
But if you're confused
about something,
also feel free to contact
me or meet and set up
a time to meet or come after
class or before class to talk.
Because we're happy to help, and
we don't have explicit office
hours.
But we are around a
lot and happy to help.
So someone wrote like I
just want more insight
into power energy, time,
and work relationships,
and that's a hard question
to answer generically.
But I'm happy to sit down with
you and give you more insight.
And then some other quick
ones background of instructor,
I completely forgot to tell
you anything about myself
other than I have a
kid, which is probably
the least useful thing for you.
So I apologize for that.
So I'm a PhD in
mechanical engineering.
I hope to God I'm
in my last year.
I've been here a while.
I did my undergrad at
MIT a long time ago,
also in mechanical engineering.
And when I finished,
I spent three years
in the automotive
industry working
for Texas Instruments,
which no longer has
an automotive sensors
and controls division
but did at the time.
They sold it off, and
now it's called Sensata.
And so I worked at first
as a manufacturing engineer
and then as a design engineer,
building pressure switch
manifolds, which
go into vehicles
to ensure that the
car transmission is
in the right gear, so that
if you think you're in drive,
the car also agrees that you're
in drive and not in reverse,
for example, which is
pretty safety critical.
And then switched over to
becoming a design engineer
and primarily worked on
capacitive automotive--
capacitive sensors
which are often
used for like anti-roll
issues to make sure the car
stays flat and parallel to the
ground and doesn't flip over.
So I have design
and manufacturing
and industry experience
which was really good.
I learned a ton, but
I decided that it
wasn't as fulfilling
or my passion
to be working in
automotive industry.
I really wanted to be working
on things that were directly
if having humanitarian benefit.
And while both of
those car sensors
help a lot to not get you
dead on the road in a car,
and that's pretty important,
it wasn't a good fit for me.
So then I quit and
was a little lost,
and through a variety of
things, found myself back at MIT
working for the Media
Lab in a group called
Think Cycle and
Design that Matters.
And Design that
Matters has spun off
into its own separate nonprofit
that's run in Kendall Square.
Think Cycle is still a website.
I'm not sure how
actively it's used,
but the idea was to do
collaborative design
work for developing
countries overseas.
So that someone in
Kenya could post saying,
I need a better water
filtration system,
and someone working in the
US who had a few extra hours
could work on that problem.
Which is interesting,
but, as we'll talk about,
it's really hard to
do that kind of work
without actually going to Kenya
or wherever you need to go.
So that was one
of the challenges.
But through that,
I met Amy Smith
and met Sally [? Sesno-- ?] it's
in the Public Service Center--
and became MIT's first service
learning coordinator, which
allowed me to figure out
how to apply projects that
help people, both in
developing countries
as well as in this country,
people who are underserved
in a variety of
definitions, figure out
how students at MIT
in their classes
could be working on projects
that would help them.
So for example,
how can you learn
in 2002, which is Mechanics
of Materials, relatively
introductory course,
how can you actually
be helping people in Haiti?
And figuring out
projects, activities
that you're doing in class,
that you're learning really
hardcore engineering
or hardcore science,
or whatever can actually
be helping people
in developing countries too.
Because that tends to resonate
really well with students,
make the material
more interesting,
make you more excited
to learn the material,
and help people too.
So it was cool, and I loved
doing it for three years.
And then I said, you
know what, I really
want to be doing
these cool projects,
not just helping people do them.
So that's why I came
back to grad school.
And so my grad
school research is
in charcoal, which you'll learn
a ton about in this class,
because it's very relevant
to the class, conveniently.
And then also studying
service learning
as a pedagogical
technique in engineering.
So that's in a nutshell.
Do you guys have any other
questions about my background?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you mind
sharing what year was it when
the first--
what year was it when you were
the first service coordinator?
Service learning coordinator?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
I think it was 2002
that I started that.
Somewhere around there.
AUDIENCE: Everything is so far
developed down that road now.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
No.
MIT has changed a ton.
Like I've been here
since '94, and MIT
has changed a ton in almost
two decades in a lot of ways.
And many ways that I'm
quite jealous that I didn't
have D-Lab when I
was an undergrad,
didn't have service learning.
So it's great that we have it.
And just to repeat
that question,
you were asking
when I came to MIT
or when I did the Public
Service Center work.
So yeah.
So any other
questions about that?
More details about
the trip we're
going to talk about today.
Projects from last
year, and details
on the final project, a
little bit today and then more
next week.
Extent of work the D-Lab
does in developing countries,
I think we work in
more than 20 countries.
The biggest work
we do is over IAP,
when a bunch of students
travel for D-Lab development,
as well as--
what other classes travel?
AUDIENCE: Cycle Ventures.
AMY BANZAERT: Cycle Ventures.
AUDIENCE: [? Education. ?]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
The D-Lab school's
class travels.
So there's a lot of work
done over [? IP. ?] Then,
a bunch of students often get
fellowships to travel over
the summer to do work.
Amy Smith and myself and
José Gómez-Márquez and some
of the other D-Lab staff
and instructors also travel
independently to do work
in developing countries.
So we're working worldwide.
We work on almost
every continent.
Not Australia and
not Antarctica,
but pretty much other than
that, we're working on it.
And how we pick countries
is complicated and subtle.
So I won't get into that.
But there's a lot of
countries we work in,
and more are being
added regularly.
However, we try to maintain
really strong relationships
with the community
partners we work with.
So we're not just doing one-off
visit one year and then leave
and never see the
community partner again,
because that's not very useful
for the community partner.
That tends to do harm, not
good, for our relationship
and the general NGO
world's relationship
to community partners.
So we try to revisit.
So that requires a
lot of commitment.
So once we have an
established relationship,
we have to keep
going back, which
means we can only grow if
we have additional capacity
to go back to new places.
Are there any other
questions about that, just
general D-Lab stuff?
I think there's
12 D-Lab classes,
so lots of opportunities
to faux major in D-Lab,
if you so choose.
We have some students who
basically do that, or just
take one and experience it.
Enjoy it.
Yeah, there's Europe
opportunities, other stuff,
if you want to
get more involved.
OK.
So that's Muddy Cards.
So I will try to do
that relatively quickly.
But at the beginning
of every day,
make sure we review what
wasn't clear last time.
Yeah.
So next, I want to
talk about the lantern.
So as I mentioned,
they were awesome.
Here's a picture of
almost all of them,
and it was really
exciting to see them.
And what I've done is I
put them on the back walls,
and so what I'd
like everyone to do
is take two minutes to just--
if you haven't looked at
the sheet that I gave you
that gives you
feedback-- look at it.
Look at the grading
rubrics, so you
have a sense of what we valued.
And then check out the lanterns,
and see what strikes you,
both in terms of the
rubric as a really solid
or a really weak lantern.
There's nothing really
weak on that table,
but there's some that
are stronger than others.
And then also, ones
that just strike you
as ones that are some of the
best in terms of actually using
them in developing
countries, what really fits.
And try out the switches.
Some are easier to
use than others,
or more obvious to
use than others.
I think when we last played with
them, they were all working.
Hopefully, they all still are.
So just take a few minutes
just to familiarize yourself
with them, and I will give them
back to you after next week,
but I need them this week.
So I don't take them back yet.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So I'm just going to highlight
some of the cooler lanterns
that some of the students made.
There's a lot of different
form factors you can see.
This one would be
a personal lantern,
and then you switch it on,
and it has a nice reflector.
There's also some that look very
much like traditional lanterns.
One of the things I really
like about this design
is both that it has a very
simple handmade switch,
and you can see it turns
on and off like that.
And then also, the
top opens, so that you
can look inside,
understand how it works,
and if there's a problem with
it, repair it very easily.
Which is a nice aspect of
designing for any product,
and specifically in developing
countries, where getting help
for repair is harder.
We also have some
more radical designs.
For example, this I call
the light saber design,
and the intent from
the student was
that it would help you
light your way at night.
So you could hold it
as a walking stick,
and then also use it to light
whatever you needed to light.
This design hasn't
been fully realized,
in terms of the
lantern aspect of it.
But the use of the binder
clip as a switch is very cute,
and we liked it a lot.
This lantern uses a
ping pong ball diffuser,
which is a really nice
integration of found material
very effectively used to improve
the effectiveness of the light.
And you can see the whole
range of devices here,
and we just really enjoyed
seeing the tremendous variation
in all the different
devices with students
all being given the
same assignment.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMY BANZAERT: So the
variety is tremendous,
and it's really cool that
you got an assignment
to all make a lantern.
And I really can't say there's
any two that look the same--
not even close.
And part of that's the reality
of found materials and this all
being different people.
But it was nice
to see that range.
And so clearly, there's not a
mental conception of lantern
that is so rigid
that we're all going
in the same direction, which
is pretty cool, actually,
because I talked to a woman
who works for the World
Bank, focused on
lighting and [AUDIO OUT]
and they've really pushed lately
for better lanterns in Africa.
Because 10 or 15 years
ago, all the lanterns
basically looked like
Coleman camping lanterns.
Because that was the designer's
conception of lantern,
and that's what
they built. Which
is a really limiting
problematic situation
for the whole different range
of lighting needs in Africa.
And Africa itself, we talked
about it, and it's a continent,
and it's a big continent.
So it's like talking about the
needs of America's, including
North and South
America and saying,
oh, yeah, we all need
the same exact shoe.
And no one in this room is
even wearing the same shoe,
because we all have different
needs just within this room,
and we're a pretty uniform
community in some respects.
In other respects
not so much, but in
some respects very uniform.
And yet we all need
different shoes,
and similarly we might all
need different lanterns.
And so if you abstract
that to-- or expand
that to all of Africa and all
the different lantern needs,
that's huge.
And yet all the lanterns are
looking like Coleman lanterns
or kerosene lanterns.
It's very limiting.
So I was really excited
to see the range.
What else did you guys notice?
AUDIENCE: The switches
were pretty unique.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
The switches were unique.
Some were very easy to
understand, easy to use.
Both handmade and off-the-shelf
ones that were grabbed.
Others were pretty subtle
and hard to figure out,
is what I saw.
So there was a
real variety there.
And after class,
during the break,
you might want to
go back and think
about what made
for a great switch
and what made for
a subtle switch.
I know like, for
example, this lantern,
the person wrote in their
write up intentionally
that they have the switch
right here to turn it on,
and it's not working anymore.
AUDIENCE: It is.
AMY BANZAERT: Oh, it is?
Oh, OK.
It is.
And so they said, oh, but
that looks kind of ugly.
So I'm going to add
these wires here,
so that the aesthetic
is a little bit better.
Which is a really nice
thought, except the result
is that the switch
is really buried.
So you have no-- it took me
quite a while to figure out,
without reading
the instructions,
and I didn't read the
instructions unless I had to.
Oh, how is this going to work?
It takes a while to
figure out, and there
is a realm of design where
it's appropriate to make
things subtle.
But for the type of
design we're going
to be doing, where we're working
with people who are definitely
not-- almost definitely
not going to be reading
instructions, and
a variety of people
are going to be
using it, you always
want it to be very evident
how the device works,
so that people can use
it without instructions.
Anything else you guys noticed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess when I
approached the project,
I was like, OK, so she wants
a lantern not a flashlight.
And so the challenging
part was in seeing
I think we're all really
resourceful, because there are
like [INAUDIBLE] and there
was, like, an eyeglass,
like a case for eyeglasses.
So that's really fun to see.
So it's challenging like to--
I really wanted to meet the
expectations of the assignment,
but it was so broad that
I was like, oh my god,
what does she want us to do?
Should it be, like, be
channeled in one direction?
Should it [INAUDIBLE] radially?
Oh, my gosh.
So I don't know how limited
we're going to be in our design
in these developing countries.
But--
AMY BANZAERT: I think
this is very real world,
that no one says,
I want a flashlight
that looks exactly like this.
And even if they do,
they rarely mean,
and if it looks exactly like
this, I'll be happy with it.
Because when you're not a
designer or an engineer,
and you're talking
about a product,
it's really hard to talk
beyond what you've seen
and what you've experienced.
And it's rare that what
you've seen and experienced
is sufficient for what
your actual needs are.
So part of the
challenge is how do I
dig down, ask the
right questions,
talk to my users to really
understand what they need,
as opposed to what they say
they need, which may or may not
match?
And why you really
want to respect
your user and their requests and
really understand the impetus
behind all their requests.
Some are really confusing to
you and really legitimate,
and others are really confusing
to you, or really clear to you,
and not entirely what they mean.
So for example, we
were just talking
about this the other day in
D-Lab, that oftentimes women
who spend a lot of
hours collecting
water and/or collecting
wood value that time,
because it means they're
away from their family.
They get a little break.
It's the only time they
get away from the house,
and they get to hang
out with their friends
and go for a long walk.
And that can be a
really nice thing,
and so eliminating that
time without building
in the other opportunity
for that socialization
means they've just lost a
key part of their daily life
that they value.
And so they may say,
oh, well, thanks
a lot for making this more
efficient stove or whatever,
but I would rather
keep using my old one.
Not because I don't
like the new efficiency
or the new lack of
smoke, but because I
miss the time with my friends.
And that's so important to
my mental health and sanity
and well-being that I'm still
going to go collect the wood.
And so there's a
million examples
of why projects like this fail,
and so it's really important
when you're talking
to your users
to understand all
these subtle elements.
And so if someone might
very offhand mention,
it's nice to talk to my friends.
And if you don't pick up
on that as a huge need,
you may design something that's
going to flop for that reason.
And so here, you didn't
really have a chance
to talk to any user.
I just said, make a lantern.
But that is the open-ended
thing that you often
get from customers.
So yeah.
OK.
So overall, yeah, great job.
You got the specific feedback.
Yeah.
OK.
So are there any other
questions or comments?
OK.
So I just wanted to do a little
review on the human power
stuff.
So you guys all got to
try out the tump line.
You can see, where it actually
goes on your head varies.
These are both cloth tump lines.
I've seen them made out of
bark, a variety of things.
Yeah, but you can see the
absurd amount of weight
that you can carry
with a tump line.
Like these are
full Coke bottles,
and that is really a
ridiculous amount of weight.
And the lab assignment
includes reading up
on these a little bit more,
so I'm to let you do that
and not talk about them right
now, but they're very cool.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: How long do they
walk with that [INAUDIBLE]??
AMY BANZAERT: All day.
Yeah.
And then the head carry, so you
can see the variety of devices.
There's not the huge
variety, But you
do see like both the
[? Jerry ?] can and the more
traditional water carrying.
And you see all sorts
of ridiculous things
or amazing things
on people's head.
And the thickness
of this fabric part
that separates your head from
whatever you're carrying really
varies, depending
on cultural norms.
So you'll see a whole range
from like you can barely
see it to something like
this, which is quite thick.
We use quite thick just
because I find it easier,
and I figure you'll
find it easier too.
It's pretty normal to get
help bringing it up and down.
So getting that
help wasn't a cheat,
but it's also pretty normal
to be using no hands,
and none of us were able to
pull that off, unsurprisingly.
One thing we didn't
really talk about
is pedal power, which is a
huge part of human power.
And that's a little
bit of your assignment
too, so I'm not going to
go into that too much.
This whole thing is
from Jody [? Wu, ?]
who was one of those D-Lab
majors I talked about,
who took as many D-Lab classes
as she could take, and is now
working on a company.
She owns a company in Tanzania,
doing pedal-power devices that
came out of her D-Lab work.
And there's a whole
variety of people
where these pictures came from.
But so pedal power, all
the way from the bicycle,
which you're used
to, a completely home
built bicycle, which would
be rather challenging to ride
but is pretty amazing.
To something like a bicycle but
is just basically using wheels.
Both for going down hills and
up hills, because carrying loads
is always an issue, and the
assumption of good roads
is not a good one.
To a pedal-powered device that
looks kind of like a sewing
machine power, but
instead is powering--
the-- what is it? $100 laptop?
Is that what it's called?
Or $200 now?
I forget.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, OLPC.
That's it.
Thanks.
Yeah.
This is a pedal-powered
compressor,
which is an interesting
project, because pedal power is
the exactly wrong
technology to use here.
Because when the
pressure tank is empty,
you have to be
pedaling incredibly
quickly to get any
pressure built up,
because there's no back pressure
for you to pedal against.
And when it's full, you have
an infinite amount of pressure
to push against, and so
you can't pedal at all.
And in fact, there's
a really handy device
that works for this great
that uses arm power,
and of course, you could
think of a foot version.
But this is just a reminder that
pedal power has a near infinite
number of uses, but
not literally infinite.
There are some places where
pedal power is ridiculous.
This is a pedal-powered
grinder, I think for corn.
People carry amazing
loads on bikes as well,
and these are bikes
specially modified
to allow for carrying loads.
We usually think of pedal
power as two-wheeled bikes,
but three wheels is
really common too
and can offer a lot
of stability benefits.
Pedal-powered
ambulances, there's
a lot of places in this
country, and more so in Europe,
where pedal power is standard
in more developed countries
as well.
And we're seeing it more
in Cambridge, actually.
There's a lot of
pedal-power delivery
now in Cambridge, which is
kind of cool, though harder
right now in this season,
with all our snow.
Variety of folding bikes
or different orientations
of bikes, a variety of
different things carrying,
amazing bikes for
going on water.
These are pedal-powered
washing machines that were--
I don't know about
this one, but there
was a collaboration
between D-Lab
and a group in Guatemala
that does pedal power
to build a washing machine.
Pedal-powered water
pumps, coffee de-pulper,
maize sheller, washing machine,
blender, plow, knife sharpener,
soap blender, nut sheller, saw.
More washing machine pics.
This is the group in Guatemala.
Maize grinder, again,
woodworking lathe, corn
shelling, so there's
a ridiculous number
of ways to use pedal power.
And because most of you
hopefully have ridden a bike,
and there's a lot of
technologies in D-Lab
that are more familiar with
pedal power than the pumping
that we showed.
That's why we went for pumping
rather than pedal power.
But it is something
to keep in mind,
as you're thinking
about projects,
that pedal power is pretty
powerful and awesome.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So now, we're going to
talk about power generally,
and one of the
biggest challenges
is that power is really
generated where you need it
or when you need it.
So for example, the sun is
only out for some portion
of the day, and in the winter,
in New England, even less.
And in Norway, where my
brother lives, even less,
and on super cloudy days,
it's a whole lot less useful.
So that's a question of when,
and that's true for wind
as well, the when is an issue.
And then the where is an issue.
Very few people want
to live right next door
to a nuclear power plant
or a coal-fired plant,
nor is it preferable to.
And for like
microhydro systems, you
may not want to live
right on the river.
You may want to
live a bit further.
So what are the solutions
that humanity has come up with
to address that issue?
AUDIENCE: Power grid.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So we have grids.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
transmission works.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, which
include transmission lines.
AUDIENCE: Ways to store
the power before they
had to transport it.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
And then we have
storage and transport.
Absolutely.
And so with-- so we're going to
talk about both of those today.
And so what are the
limitations of grids?
What are the challenges
you face with any grid?
AUDIENCE: It's difficult
to actually set up
a the large-scale grid.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, but what
do you mean by difficult?
AUDIENCE: Well it's
very money intensive,
if you want to string up
a highly efficient grid.
It's the main reason why the
US is actually still working
on a grid system developed,
like, a hundred years ago.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So grids are incredibly
capital intensive,
if you're doing a big grid.
Juan.
AUDIENCE: Change of
voltage, as you go across
you have to increase
it for long distance
and then decrease it
back to usable power.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, and do why
you have the change of voltage?
AUDIENCE: Efficiency.
When you're transferring
it through the--
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
So you have loss issues that
you need to take into account.
I saw a lot of hands.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] So part
of the-- one of the smart grid
technologies is [INAUDIBLE] to
the phase meter [INAUDIBLE]..
But in reality, like, today,
all they have is, like,
people at different
substations, and just like
crank it up, crank
it down a little bit,
depending on how it's
coming [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Although I think
the problem with grids
from a policy
standpoint is that,
once the infrastructure
is there,
they are there for
long periods of years.
And so it's really
hard to regulate,
because you have so many
different [INAUDIBLE] regions.
So these are transmission lines
going across different states.
Then, you get to the issue of
is it the federal government
or is it us?
And so just, like,
imagine regulating
all those policies [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Absolutely.
So we have issues with,
once they're in place,
they're in place forever.
The efficiency,
you can do things
to improve the
efficiency, but you're
going to have losses always.
And then policy and ownership
issues are challenging as well.
I saw a few other hands.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When there's storms,
and you have a power outage,
it's a problem.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So storms, and I'd say more
generally maintenance for--
typical and atypical
situations is always an issue.
Any others?
Yeah, Missy.
AUDIENCE: You usually have to
use it [INAUDIBLE] generate,
like, [INAUDIBLE] or like--
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So it's-- there is no
storage in a typical grid.
So lack of storage is an issue.
Yeah, and then getting
to storage and transport,
and for that, we're going
to focus on batteries.
There are a few other
options, but the most common
is batteries.
So what are some issues
around batteries?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] good life.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the life is an issue.
AUDIENCE: Disposal.
AMY BANZAERT: Disposal,
which is very linked to life.
AUDIENCE: According
to our problem set,
it actually doesn't
carry that much energy.
So it's not very good.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the density, the energy
density of batteries,
it's pretty poor compared to
a lot of other technologies
we're used to.
Any other thoughts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The materials
are like that you need
to use and make the battery.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the materials,
that can be an issue
for environmental reasons.
It can be an issue for
cost and just availability.
There are some materials
we use that we literally
have a fixed amount of,
and we're running out.
Some other things?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One more thing the
batteries is just their design
constraints, as far as
usually you use them
for small portable devices.
Yet the smaller the battery,
the less energy it provides.
So it's just the [? naivete ?]
that design problems.
AMY BANZAERT: Well, I don't
if it's exactly the right way
to say it, but the way
I'm going to say it
is that the size and the
weight of the battery
versus its utility
to you is inversely
proportional and
a bit of a bummer.
So you want, for getting a
really good storage capability,
you generally need a big,
large, heavy battery.
And typically, you want as
light and small of battery
as possible.
So that's a pretty
frustrating conflict.
Yeah.
Let's start with grids.
So all of these
are major issues,
and I want to start by
talking about the US grid
just for a minute.
So this is what the
US grid looks like.
This is a really nice
interactive graph from NPR.
The link is on the slide
notes, and you can go to it
and play with it.
And you can see all of the
different transmission lines,
and all these voltages are
incredibly high compared
to what you're used to using.
But you can see there's
a range of sizes,
because the higher you have
to transform the voltage,
the more expensive it is.
But you can see,
this is our major--
these are our major currents
on the eastern seaboard.
So that is just an
interesting thing to note.
And then in terms of the
power plants in the US,
you can see just how
spread out they are
and how varying in size.
And therefore, how
critical our grid system
is in order to get the
power to where we need it.
Otherwise, people in
Maine, for example,
would not have
much power at all,
and you can see other
parts of the country
where the power would be
really limited otherwise.
And then this is just
I just want to show you
this, because it goes
down and shows you
all the different plant
types you can have.
And then you can
click on the plants,
you can go to each state and
compare where we get our power.
So for example,
in Massachusetts,
for primarily gas, whereas
in Vermont, they're
primarily nuclear.
So it's just really interesting
to see, even within the US,
how much variation
there is in states
right next to each other,
let alone across the country.
You can also see what
the solar opportunities
are in the country.
And if we're going to
go to primarily solar,
we have to figure
out a way to transmit
the power from in
this realm all the way
across the whole
country, if we're
going to be successful
with solar power.
And similarly with
wind power, some
of the eastern and western
seaboard look great,
but then the center
of the country
is kind of in trouble,
if we just go with wind.
So comparing the
amount of wind power
to say the number of power
plants that are in existence,
wind there's a whole lot
less well distributed
than what we've got right now.
So yeah.
This is just a very
cool demo to give you
a sense of the US
grid really quickly.
OK.
So now, it's time to do
some equations to think
about the line losses that
you have to deal with.
So the line losses
are all due to what?
AUDIENCE: Heating.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
heating of the wire.
And why is the
wire being heated?
AUDIENCE: Current throught it.
AMY BANZAERT: Because it
has current through it,
and a wire has some resistance.
So the equation for
that is Joule's Law,
and is defined as Q is equal
to-- which is the heat--
is to the square
of current times
the resistance times the
time, and that's Joule's Law.
And if you're not
super-comfortable
with your double-E,
you're probably
going to say, oh, well, the I
R, that sounds like a voltage,
and throw a voltage in there,
and you're missing a subtlety.
Because then you'd
say, oh, well,
it's related to current and
voltage at the same level.
But you have to figure out what
voltage you're calculating,
because if you
recall, while current
is going through the whole wire
at the same rate everywhere,
because it's a flow,
a voltage is based
on a comparison of two places.
And you have to compare
the right voltage in order
to plug that into the
equation correctly.
So we're not going
to do that right now,
but we're going to go through
this equation in a little
more detail.
So hopefully, it becomes
a little more intuitive.
So let's pretend
that we're trying
to deliver power from some
power plant in western Mass
to Boston.
And so we're going to call
that power that we need power
with a capital P. And power,
as we recall, is the voltage,
and that's from the
line to ground times
the resistance through the
power line, so P equals VI.
But we also have the
issue of the power loss
that we know is happening
through the wire.
So to calculate that you're
using the same equation.
We're going to call
that lowercase p is
equal to voltage from
the end of the line
to the beginning of the line.
So L1 to L2, times I.
These I's, thankfully,
for just thinking--
for minimizing how much
confusion, are the same I.
They're the same current
going through the wire, which
is going to be the same
throughout the entire wire.
But the voltage here,
for big P, we're
worrying about
checking the voltage
at one end of the line
or the other to ground.
And little p, we're worrying
about the voltage drop from one
end of the line to the other.
So for example, let's say
the power plant is providing
10,000 volts [INAUDIBLE].
Like, where on the boat can I
write, and you can still see?
Like, if I write down to
there, can you see it?
No?
No is a better answer
than blank stare.
So all right.
Can you see this range?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
And this is going
to make me batty.
OK.
So we have 10,000 volts.
So the voltage here from line
to ground at the power plant
is 10,000, and then let's say
we lose 1,000 volts across here
due to line losses.
So that this would be this V,
and this would be V L minus G.
And then conveniently,
so then we
know we have the V at the end.
It's just going
to be 9,000 volts.
So this is pretty
simple math, hopefully.
So power, the lowercase p,
is equal to the voltage drop
across the line, so V
L1 to L2 times I. Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm getting myself confused.
So power is equal to--
power is also equal
to I squared times R--
that I. So our options
are we can make our V--
sorry.
I just got totally
lost in my notes.
So let me start again.
Right.
OK.
So we have these two equations.
We're not going to worry
about numbers right now.
So we want to maximize
this P and minimize that p.
And we know the relationship
between these two V's.
So then, so if we
minimize I, we minimize
that power, which is good.
But we also minimize
this power, which is bad.
And that's why we're trying
to pop up the voltage
to be as high as possible,
so that we can maximize
power and minimize our losses.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
I know, I got lost
in the middle.
OK.
If it doesn't,
and you don't want
to talk about it right now,
you can talk to me after class.
We can go through it then.
So that is great in a macrogrid.
So we can bump up the voltage,
super, and for all set.
However, in a microgrid,
bumping up the voltage,
transforming the voltage is
really, really expensive.
So in a microgrid,
you don't do that.
You just use your given voltage,
which saves you a lot of money
but also means that
line losses are huge.
And so for in that case, if
you can't change your voltage,
what is your loss based on?
You already answered it.
It's the resistance in the wire
is what we have to worry about.
So the resistance in the wire
is based on rho L over A,
where rho is equal to
the inherent resistivity,
L is the length,
and A is the area
in cross section of your wire.
And so for your
resistivity, that
means you're picking your wire.
So you could use an aluminum
wire or a copper wire
or what have you.
Copper tends to have the best
resistivity of the options,
but copper is also
incredibly expensive,
if for no other reason
then because people
are stealing copper all
over countries and the US.
So people who have beautiful
rain gutters made of copper no
longer do, because
people are stealing them,
because copper is scarce
and expensive these days.
Length, so copper,
your resistivity
is probably going to
be basically fixed
based on your costs.
Length is something you can
control but is also a bummer.
Because if you go too far--
if you want to
power a house that's
an extra few blocks
down, you can't if you're
limited by your length.
And then your area,
your diameter, again,
is going to be completely
related to cost.
So from a cost standpoint,
you want a really small area,
but to minimize your resistance,
you want a really large area.
So yeah.
So let's run through
the calculation just
to hopefully make this clearer.
So in teams of a
couple of people,
if you can run through this.
So typical jumper
cables are helping
to provide a jump to
a dead car battery
from an existing
working car battery.
So you're providing somewhere
on the order of 400 amps
at 12 volts, and the typical
diameter of a jumper cable
is a wire gauge of 4, which
translates to 2/10 of an inch
in diameter.
Versus a typical wire like
you used on your lanterns
is on the order of
a wire gauge of 26,
which is a much, much,
much smaller diameter.
And so we're going to
assume are using copper.
So that's the copper
resistivity length,
and so now what I want
you to do is figure out
what length of cable can be
used for each wire gauge,
so that you still--
so that your losses
don't dominate over
your transmission.
Does this question make sense?
I'm seeing a lot
of confused faces.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So let's say, we can't lose--
you can define how
much you can lose,
because again, this is
open ended, intentionally
open ended.
But if you're losing 100%--
if all your power is going
to heat, that's a problem.
And why don't you set what
percent can go to heat
and then figure out
what length you can use.
OK.
So I think most people are done.
So I'm just going to get a range
of where we are in the class.
So can someone
just shout out what
you got for the 26 gauge, the 4
gauge, and the percentage loss
you assumed?
Like I know you guys--
AUDIENCE: 0.55.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: And another team?
AUDIENCE: 0.01.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: It's 10.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 10 there.
AUDIENCE: And it's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's also
0.1 for the first time.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: No, it's
10 centimeters.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it was 0.1
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE] yeah.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AMY BANZAERT: Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: About 9 centimeters.
And we said 14.6 meters.
AMY BANZAERT: 14 meters?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for 40%.
AMY BANZAERT: So these
are all looking--
there's clearly something
subtle going on.
We're not getting
it quite right,
but we're all getting the
order of magnitude correct.
So I'm happy.
This [? is ?] class is not
about getting an exact answer,
but getting the gist
down, and it looks good.
Is there a team that
got wildly different?
I think there's at least one.
AUDIENCE: We got 0.36
AMY BANZAERT: 0.36
meters and what?
AUDIENCE: We didn't
calculate the--
AMY BANZAERT: OK, and what
was your percent loss?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: 33%
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMY BANZAERT: 33%.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Sorry, no, it's 1/6.
We lost 2 votes out of 12 votes.
That's 1/6.
AUDIENCE: No, power loss.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Is it according to
the power loss or voltage?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Same thing.
AUDIENCE: It's the same.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's 1/6.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Never mind.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So basically, this is on
the order of a length of--
a jumper cable is usually
between 2 and 3 meters.
And these are all
really big losses.
Like, your wires are going
to get super dangerously hot,
if you're losing
this much power.
Which is fine for just doing
an order of magnitude--
where am I?
But that's why they're actually
quite a bit shorter than that.
Plus, you rarely need your
cars to be 20 meters apart,
thankfully--
or when you do, it's
really frustrating.
And then this is a reason why
jumper cables are expensive
and you need a big
diameter copper wire.
This just wouldn't work.
And so if someone, again,
consultant came to you,
or someone came to you
looking for money, saying I
have a great idea for
a new jumper cable,
and we're going to
use really thin wires.
It's going to save
us so much money.
You can do this type of
calculation really fast.
It'd be like, oh, no,
you can't, unless you
want to have magic cars that
are right next to each other.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you want to
send it [INAUDIBLE] away,
and so you just put, like,
two jumper cables lined up,
there isn't supposed
to be a loss there.
But do you know what the actual
loss is, when you, like, just
connect wire to wire for this
kind of power going through it?
AMY BANZAERT: Well,
so if you connected--
if you have your one
car and your next--
excuse me.
If you have one car and
your next car, and you're
connecting your jumper cables.
And then you say so
that's just going to work,
because it's a
normal jumper cables.
But then if your car
is, in fact, this far.
So you need another
set of cables here,
your loss is going
to go up, [INAUDIBLE]
just because the
distance is going up.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And the context
of loss [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: The loss has
to do with your contacts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is there a loss there?
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
There's going to be
losses everywhere,
but I would say the length is
going to dominate over that.
So again, this is the
type of engineering
where you focus on what's going
to dominate and pay attention
to that.
And the stuff that is small
you don't even worry about,
which is most of
engineering, until you get
into the super-detailed design.
Yeah.
So you worry about it.
And one of the
things that's really
interesting on your lanterns
is that a lot of you
didn't use wire.
You used found materials,
like paper clips and--
I can't remember the name of--
binder clips and all the
variety of things which
have decent resistance.
And yet, you have
an LED that's pretty
robust to high resistance,
and so it worked fine.
So that is one of the nice
things to think about,
is yes, you're
getting losses there.
And if you want to get--
if you want to
perfectly maximize
the light output of
your LED, then you
need to worry about it.
But if the losses are
relatively small, you're fine.
So if one of you had made a
lantern that was like somehow
had wires that
were 20 feet long,
then we're going
to start worrying,
depending on how
small your gauge is
and how high the
resistance is in the line.
But you've got some
flexibility there.
If anyone got lost here,
which is understandable,
because it's confusing, and
want to just come talk to us,
we can go through it with.
But it's important
to understand this,
because it's a useful
calculation to be able to make.
So just in summary, for
microgrids, some of the--
some of the benefits
are autonomy.
So if a community in the
middle of nowhere needs power,
you don't have to wait
until the government decides
to deliver that power to you.
You can just build
it, and you're not
reliant on the
vagaries of politics.
You can just build it.
Compatibility, microgrids
can hypothetically
attach to the macrogrid.
So that's an
opportunity, and you
can connect with some controls.
You can connect your wind
turbine and your hydro turbine
and your solar panels
all to the same grid,
and you've got some
compatibility and flexibility
opportunities there, as
well as scalability--
within the limits of
what we just talked about
of transmission line length.
You can scale your microgrid.
So you can build it small,
and then expand it as needed,
as long as you're paying
attention to you're
limiting factors.
Some of the challenges
of microgrids,
especially in
developing countries,
are there's always
going to be maintenance.
And if it's not
run by a utility,
then it's a local issue
of the maintenance.
And so who's going to
do that, and are they
going to do it well?
Limiting loads, so
in the US, we have
our fuse boxes that limit
how much power we can draw.
You don't always necessarily
have fuse boxes on a microgrid,
or you don't have ones
at each local house,
because that's expensive.
And so people might just start
plugging in stuff willy-nilly,
and then you take down
your whole microgrid.
And then also just private
versus public sector issues.
There's both issues of that
one of our community partners
faces, in Nicaragua, where
they build a microgrid.
And then for whatever
political reason,
the government
decides to install
the public grid,
and all of a sudden,
all that investment
of the microgrid
goes to waste, unless you
can tie in your microgrid
to the public grid,
which you rarely can,
because a variety of political
and technical challenges.
There's just also issues
that I referred to of,
if it's locally owned, all
those built-in bureaucracies
that actually can be
very helpful aren't there
and figuring out
how to manage that.
But microgrids do
allow you to put power
in the middle of places that
would otherwise probably
never get it, or it's going to
be another century before they
do.
So it is pretty valuable.
So with that, let's
take a 10-minute break,
and then we'll talk about
batteries and the trip.
This graph should look familiar,
both because I showed it
last week, and because you
made a vaguely similar one,
hopefully, in your
homework for today.
That batteries are brutal in
terms of the energy solutions
we're used to.
And just as a good
rule of thumb,
batteries on the order of 10
[AUDIO OUT] to 10 [AUDIO OUT]
to 0 megajoules per kilogram.
And you probably
won't memorize this.
I haven't yet, but there's 0.278
kilowatt hours to 1 mega joule.
But if you can get that
in your head, it's useful.
And capacitors, which
are another way that we
store and have even
worse life, are also
even worse in terms of use.
And then springs, which
students often suggest,
is a great way to store.
And there are some radios and
wind-up flashlights and things
like that that that it.
We're talking an even
further order of magnitude
of [? badness. ?]
And fossil fuels
are somewhere on the
order of 10 to the 1.
So again, this is why batteries
are frustrating to use
but useful.
So the other thing that--
so now, talking about
batteries, there's
a lot of different chemistries
of batteries, and more
being developed every day.
And we are going to
be likely sticking
with established technologies,
because the third dimension
on this graph, which
isn't shown, is cost.
And emergent technologies
are way off the chart
compared to, say, a lead-acid.
And lead-acid
batteries, for a lot
of the systems
we're talking about,
are still really expensive,
just because of our costs.
We're so constrained on costs.
So alkalines are common and
are relatively inexpensive.
So they're a great
technology, but the bummer
is that they're
not rechargeable.
And so you're replacing
them constantly,
which is a huge waste issue.
So that increases
their effective cost.
Yeah.
So one excellent
battery resource,
just if you're trying
to figure out batteries,
is this battery
primer put together
by David Wallace,
who's my advisor
and teaches 209, which is the
senior capstone design class.
And I stole this summary
page from that document.
So when you're worrying
about batteries,
there's a ton of different
things you have to worry about
and some of which we
talked about already.
So the physical characteristics,
the size, the shape,
and the weight.
It's really frustrating
when you need to,
for example, power an LED.
You noticed I gave you
9-volt batteries instead
of AA batteries.
Even the double A's or what
you're more familiar with,
but double A's don't have
the voltage you need,
unless you connect
them properly.
But double A's are a much
nicer form factor than 9 volts.
But you're limited there, and it
gets more extreme the more you
go into a variety of batteries.
All the different voltage
issues, we're really
talking very simplistically.
But when you really get
into batteries, figuring out
exactly what your peak load
is, how much time you have,
your current, it all matters,
and it can get complicated.
But the good thing is there's
really great handbooks
out there that explain it all.
Batteries are really
well documented.
If you get a battery spec
sheet, you see all the graphs,
you can figure out
exactly what you need.
But you do have to
realize going into it
that you have to consider
all these things,
that you can't just
grab a car battery,
and use it, and expect
it's going to work well.
So for example, a car battery,
as opposed to a deep cycle
lead acid battery,
both are lead acid.
And one of the differences
is that a car battery,
you need a high current for
a very short burst of time,
just to get the
starter motor to run.
And then your car
is set, and then you
can recharge it, thanks
to your alternator,
when you're driving your car.
So the car battery
almost never discharges,
unless you leave your
lights on all night, bummer.
And then your battery's
dead, and you probably
need a new one, if you
do that a few times.
Whereas, a solar panel
installation or wind power,
if you think about it, you
don't need a really high current
quickly.
You need a steady current
for a long period of time.
So a car battery's
chemistry, it's
not made to provide
that type of power.
So if you try to a
car battery, you're
going to kill it really
fast, because you're
discharging it too much.
And all batteries
have some lower limit
of where their discharge is, and
you can't discharge any lower.
So that means, if you're
doing anything complicated,
you can't just use a battery.
You also have to use some of
charge control or a discharge
controller, so that you
never discharge your battery
too much.
And you never overcharge it,
and all these subtleties.
So batteries are really
useful, but there's a lot
of details to worry about.
So again, as we're talking about
the duty cycling, the charging,
and the discharge cycling.
Temperature is another thing.
We're generally working in
climates that are really hot,
and batteries are ideally used
in a pretty warm environment
but not 100 degrees.
And so they don't
always work well
in degrees [? F ?] in
places we're working.
And so you have to
account for that.
Service life, so how long
do they last, and is there
going to be someone--
some budget to replace
the battery when they die?
Safety, we're all
used to alkalines,
which are pretty safe.
They rarely leak.
But a lot of the
deep-cycle batteries
can actually be
relatively unsafe.
And you need to
worry about them,
and all batteries you have
to worry about disposal.
Environment, maintenance
is a huge issue
on the cheapest
lead acid batteries,
which are what is often used.
And then the cost, both
initial and life cycle.
So there's a ton of stuff
to consider with batteries.
And then for just
simply thinking about
say a lead acid
battery, and how it's
going to integrate into your
system, and how do you size it?
So you figure out
what your source is,
and you have to think about
both your daily average
as well as your peaks and
lows on a day-to-day basis
and a seasonal basis.
So if you think about solar,
it's varying over the season,
and it's varying over
the course of the day.
Your daily average of your
load, and that also varies.
If it's hot, people
might have more fans on.
If you have a party, and you
keep your lights on for longer,
what have you.
How many days of storage?
So if you have no
days of storage,
you're just relying on the
sun, and you have a cloudy day,
it doesn't work.
Your system doesn't
work that night.
If you have a few days
of storage, great.
So typically, people put in
three to six days, depending.
And then you also have a budget.
So you can develop the
perfect battery plan
for what you need,
and then you realize
that that's going
to cost you $10,000,
and you only have $1,000.
And so then you iterate
and figure out, well,
what can you put on to pull off?
The things you're
considering are
your energy source and
usually for renewables
that's a DC source.
And then you have
a charge controller
to make sure that you
don't harm your battery,
as you're charging it,
and the charge controller
has some efficiency.
The battery can
never get too low.
And then you have an inverter
to go from DC to AC current,
and that has an efficiency all
the way to get to your AC load.
In some places-- like,
for example, on boats--
they just use DC lighting,
and everything is--
on certain boats,
everything is just
DC, so you don't have
to use the inverter,
and that's an option too.
But a lot of people
want appliances
that are not DC
appliances, because those
are a limited set.
So they're all just
different issues to consider.
So now, I want to-- are there
any questions on batteries?
I know this was ridiculously
fast and limited,
but it's hard to--
it's more interesting and useful
to talk about the batteries,
once what you actually need.
And so that's why I'm
trying to just give you
the resource of what you
might need to think about
and where you can go
to think about it.
There's also a handbook that
David Wallace references.
That's where he got
all of that stuff.
That's really good.
That's on my desk today.
So you can look at it
right now, after class,
if you're interested.
But then it's going
back to the library,
because it's due today.
But you can check it
out from [? Barker. ?]
There's lots of resources.
So are there any questions
on batteries just generally?
OK.
So now, what I want you to
do is two estimation sets,
again in groups and
again trying to vary
who you're working with.
Because you don't know who
you'll be going on the trip
with, if you're going on
the trip, and who your team
will be with post-trip.
So it's nice to get a sense
of everyone in the class
and get comfortable
working with them.
So one is estimating the power
required for typical objects
that you might encounter
in your daily life,
and then probably building off
of that estimation, each person
doing a separate one.
But you can work together
to help you figure it out,
how much you think
you consume daily.
And everyone needs to get how
much energy you consume daily,
and everyone needs to get
to the personal daily energy
consumption number.
You need to get a number.
We can probably take, like, 15
minutes to get to that number,
because you're going
to-- this is going
to be related to the homework.
So everyone needs to
turn in a number to me,
and I'll have a
sheet going around,
so everyone can
write down what you
think your personal
energy consumption is
on a daily basis.
And again, I know
your days vary.
Some days you cook with
an oven, and some days you
don't, but some random average.
Any questions on this?
Juan.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
energy consumption,
say you buy food at a store
for a day, or you don't cook,
should you kind of
[? estimate ?] I guess
remind me that they
probably cook it in an oven,
and it probably took
this many watts?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
So just a general guess.
This is a challenging
assignment,
because it's really--
there's so many times
that you're dealing with energy
that is out of your control.
The majority of
your life is energy
that you have no control over.
This building is
often 85 degrees,
and that wasn't something you
chose or something I chose.
But there you are, and what
percentage of this building
is your fault?
That's a really strange thing
to think about and calculate,
so you just do your best.
The other thing
is you should only
be talking about
consumable energy.
So you don't need to worry
about the energy required
to build your laptop,
just the energy you're
pulling to power the laptop,
as they're using it that day.
Does that make sense?
Any other questions?
OK.
So get started.
[? Amin ?] and I are here
if you have questions.
So I have seen a few orders
of magnitude variation
in what you guys put.
So this is actually part of
your homework assignment.
So definitely, you'll
want to go back and do
some sanity checking
on your number.
And then also, just
naturally, there
will be some refinement when
you do it for your homework.
But yeah, make sure what
number you just wrote down,
because you're going to use that
in the homework to compare it
to the value,
recalculate, et cetera,
but I'll talk about the
homework in a minute.
So now, are there any
questions on this?
All these numbers and
whatever else you used,
it's relatively easy to google.
So I wanted you to
first do the estimation.
So you got to practice
with estimation,
but now you can just
google it and look it up.
I recommend when
you google to look
for at least three corroborating
sources that have different--
that aren't self-referenced,
before you trust it,
if you're going to do Google.
Because as all-knowing
as Wikipedia is,
it's often off, and
so are other sources.
So Google's fast.
So if you're not going to get
a real reference text that's
actually believable, then
definitely get a few sources
before you rely on it.
OK.
So the spring break trip.
You guys, of course,
had questions about it.
So we're going to Nicaragua,
which is south of here.
So spring break is
this week, and we
try to go Saturday
through Saturday.
But because of
plane ticket costs,
sometimes, we travel
on a Friday or Saturday
or Sunday on both ends.
So I will put up
shortly a form online
for you to tell
me like would you
be available to
travel on a Friday.
Some of you might have classes
after this class, in which case
that would be no.
Some of you don't, and so
students who didn't last year
just skipped the day of class--
this lab on the Friday, with
my permission obviously,
to fly to Nicaragua to
make it more affordable.
So one of the
questions on here will
be like what is your flexibility
for arriving and departing?
So that we can minimize plane
ticket costs for ourselves.
But those are the
approximate dates.
The cost for you.
So for D-Lab trips,
students contribute
$500 which usually does not
even cover the cost of the plane
ticket, but allows us to make
it possible for most students
to travel who want to.
If $500 is personally
prohibitive for you,
you can come talk
to me, and we can
see if we can get you a
scholarship for the trip.
But otherwise, it really
allows D-Lab to do
a lot of great stuff to have
your contribution that we
couldn't do if we
paid everything.
Also, like $500 is
an amazing bargain
for the trip you're going on.
And it's nice to have
you personally contribute
to what you're doing.
And then also we don't
cover things like medical.
You'll need some vaccines,
at MIT Medical probably.
Those cost a little bit.
We don't pay for those.
If you need a passport and/or
a visa, that's something
you cover on your own.
Then, when you're in country,
you pay for your own food.
It works out to usually
a few dollars a day.
So it's pretty affordable
compared to here.
And then we usually give gifts
to our community partners,
and that's something that
comes out of your own pocket.
They're generally
very modest, both
because of our own
personal budgets,
and it's pretty, at least to
some, uncomfortable situations
that we'll talk about later.
If you go to this place where
people are earning $2 a day
and present them with something
that's worth a ton of money,
it's problematic for
a lot of reasons.
So it's not prohibitive,
but I'm trying
to make sure you guys are
clear on all the costs.
But we make sure
that you get there
with the plane ticket,
housing, transportation, all
that stuff is covered.
Do you have any
questions on the costs?
And the way you pay this is
you can write a check to D-Lab,
generally.
It's pretty easy.
AUDIENCE: If you have a US
passport do you get your visa?
AMY BANZAERT: You
will not need a visa
if you have a US passport.
And many other countries
don't require a visa.
Some do.
The cost of the visa,
I think last year,
was on the order
of like $80 or $90.
Something like that.
We can figure it out.
So things to do now.
There's a lot of things that
need to be posted tonight.
So you can't literally
do it right after class,
but one is it'll be a form
online just to get details,
if you are hoping
to go on the trip
that you should fill out
ideally before Friday's class.
Two is check your
passport to make
sure it expires more than
six months from March,
because if it doesn't,
you'll need to renew it.
Because you're sometimes
barred from traveling,
if your passport
expires too soon,
because they don't trust that
you'll be able to get back
into your home country,
and they don't want
you stuck in their country.
So we need to make sure
that it doesn't expire.
And if it does, if
you process it now,
it's a whole lot
cheaper than if you
have to do it the night before,
and a lot less stressful,
which is why to check now.
You need to make a travel clinic
appointment at MIT Medical,
or you can go to a different
travel clinic if you prefer.
But MIT Medical
is easy and their
experienced for your vaccines.
There's a variety of
things you may need.
One thing I would encourage
you to talk to them
about is whether you want
to do malaria or not.
Malaria meds have
some side effects
that have bothered
students in the past.
So some people opt to risk it.
The risk of malaria
is relatively low,
in Nicaragua, where we'll
be, but it's non-zero.
So it's up to you
and your doctor
to decide where you fall
on that cost-benefit ratio,
but it is something
to discuss with them
rather than just
taking it immediately.
And then make sure they
will, but make sure
they give you a prescription for
Cipro or a similar antibiotic,
so that if you do
get sick in country,
you can take an
antibiotic without having
to find a clinic that has
it, which can be challenging.
But that's standard.
They'll do that at MIT, but
in case you go somewhere else.
And then the other thing is to
figure out, ideally by Friday,
because the sooner we buy plane
tickets, the more affordable
they'll be.
If you're prepared to
commit to the trip,
and if you're going
on the trip, we're
really expecting that you're
committing to the class
as well.
Because we're investing a lot
on you to take you on the trip.
And so while drop date
is after the trip,
and you could drop it, we're
really expecting that you
won't.
So it's on your honor.
There's nothing I can do,
but you do need to commit.
The other thing is if
you commit to the trip,
and we buy your plane tickets,
and then you back out,
you will be responsible for the
cost of the plane ticket, which
is on the order of $600.
Yeah.
So you do need to
decide, am I doing this?
Am I not?
And then I'll post the packing
list again tonight or tomorrow.
You obviously don't need
to start packing today,
unless you're incredibly
like my mother,
packing months in advance.
But it is helpful to see like,
oh, I don't have any summer
clothing right now that I'm
willing to bring to Nicaragua
and probably have trash.
So you can order it now
rather than figuring it out
the night before to start
thinking about that.
Are there any other
questions about the trip
that I can answer?
AUDIENCE: As far as
like, I mean, obviously
I'm not packing now, but
for clothing and stuff,
what's appropriate there?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So you want to be
relatively conservative,
so you don't want to be
wearing like super thin tank
tops and stuff.
Sometimes, it's OK
to wear a tank top.
Oftentimes, you want to have at
least your shoulders covered.
And then you wouldn't want
to wear any short shorts,
but stuff that comes down
below your knee and/or skirts
and pants.
Nicaragua is pretty
chill about this stuff
compared to some
places that D-Lab goes.
The women don't only have
to wear dresses and things
like that, which is a nice
thing about Nicaragua.
But we do try to
dress conservatively,
and one of the things
students questioned
last year is they
would see people
on the street dressing
entirely not conservatively,
and what's going on there?
And it's because when we're in
more rural areas, number one,
there's a more
conservative culture.
And we are going to
pretty rural areas.
Number two is that we are
representing MIT, the United
States, et cetera, et cetera.
And so we don't want to
be on the edge of things
that people might
find offensive,
even though some other
people might wear it.
We want to be looking as
professional and respectful
as possible.
So even though you might
see people wearing stuff
that I specifically
said not to wear,
there's a reason I said that.
It's not just
because I'm uptight.
It's because I want to
make sure that we're
presenting a respectful face
to our community partners.
It's really hot in Nicaragua.
So you definitely
want light clothes,
as light clothes as possible.
Like we recommend people
bring like a light fleece,
because it might
get cold at night,
but oftentimes, it's never used.
Other times, it is.
Nicaragua doesn't have a
huge seasonal variation,
but it still varies a bit.
You'll definitely
want a swimsuit
and, again, something on
the more conservative side
is better than a Brazilian
bikini for this trip.
Any other questions about that?
The purpose of the trip, which
I completely skipped over,
seems like a relevant
thing to bring up.
The main thrust of this
class is the projects
that we're going
to be working on.
And I'll talk more
about them next week.
But they're projects that are
beneficial to our community
partners, ideally are beneficial
to a broad scale of people.
So that we're
working specifically
with specific
clients, but it's not
just hypothetically a one-off.
It could have greater impact.
And so the idea is that
starting next week, likely,
you guys will be
working to start
thinking about those projects
as part of the homework
and going through the very
initial stages of the design
process, so that when
you're in country,
you can talk to them
about, hey, this
is the idea, what
we're thinking about.
This is what it'll look like.
What do you think about this?
Give me feedback.
And so that way you can really
get a lot of information
very quickly.
That is much, much harder
to get if you don't travel.
So that's the idea,
as well as just
to be familiar with
the different country
and what life is like there.
It's a pretty great
experience for most people
that really enriches your
educational experience just
period, to get to travel
to a developing country
and see how great
and how challenging
life can be in a
different place.
So it's both from a
project standpoint
and a general standpoint.
Jess.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this I can
ask you about after class.
But could you talk a little bit
about the security and safety
issues [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So Nicaragua, the people
I know who go down there
or who live and work
down there consider
it comparable to
any place in the US
that's relatively on
the dangerous side.
So it is no more dangerous
than spending time
in New York, New York City,
or something like that.
It's different.
You probably don't speak
the language as well.
You're not familiar with things.
So you have to be
more on your guard
than you might be in New York.
But in terms of actual
dangers, it's relatively low.
There have been some issues
more recently in Managua,
the capital city, with people--
kidnapping scams
with taxis, where
you don't know, where
you get into a taxi,
and then they mug
you, basically.
So we don't use taxis where
we don't know the taxi
driver personally.
And we have a lot of
connections in Nicaragua
which allows us to
maintain your safety.
So what we do is we take
all reasonable precautions.
Can I guarantee that
nothing will happen?
Absolutely not.
Do we help prepare
you to make sure
that we minimize the chances
of anything happening?
Definitely.
And I think chances are
good that you will come back
with all your belongings and
everything intact, no problem.
But of course, I
can't guarantee it,
just as I can't guarantee
you won't get mugged walking
home to your dorm tonight.
It's just a reality of life,
but it is relatively safe.
You can go on the
US Embassy sites--
I think it's US Embassy--
US government sites to read up
on what they recommend about
travel in Nicaragua and what
are the specific dangers,
if there's something
you're concerned about.
But I've traveled there
four times last year,
and I brought
expensive equipment.
Though I was very good
about only taking it out
when I was inside
a secure location
and keeping it very secure,
and nothing disappeared.
I had no problem.
I had a student this past
summer who was there,
and she had $30 stolen out
of her shoe or something
like that, but that was fine.
So we've never had something
more significant than that.
But it is always a risk.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where in
Nicaragua are we going?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So I'm still figuring that out.
Last year, we
worked near Ocotal.
So Managua is the capital
city where we'll fly into.
And so last year, so
we flew into Managua.
One group worked up in Ocotal.
One group worked in Bluefields,
on the Atlantic coast,
which is a very different
population than the Pacific
coast.
The Atlantic coast has a
lot of Caribbean influence,
as well as Indigenous
populations at a high level.
And so it's a really
interesting part of the country,
but it's very
expensive, so we may not
be able to afford to
go there this year.
So we worked in
Ocotal and Bluefields
and in the Matagalpa area.
We may go to Jinotega this year
as well, and the way it works
is that you're on a mini team,
and the team goes to one place.
So last year, one team went
to Bluefields, one place
to Ocotal, one team to
Matagalpa type of thing.
So I don't know exactly
where we'll be going.
It'll be relatively rural.
Yeah.
So there's not a great answer.
It's real time figuring it out
with our community partners
right now.
So as I know more,
you'll know more.
So the Poor People's Energy
Outlook, was it helpful?
Was it surprising?
AUDIENCE: I thought the
focus on the opportunity cost
was really interesting.
So energies that [INAUDIBLE]
like providing energy
for themselves, where
energy access is poor
is just a really big deal.
And I was actually
pretty surprised
to hear you say that it was
like a leisure activity.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So it's
both a leisure activity
and a huge hassle.
It's a combo.
And so the issue is,
would most people
prefer not to be carrying
65 pounds of wood
back and forth for a
few miles every day?
Of course, absolutely.
But is there an
aspect of that that's
important culturally
or personally?
Yes.
And so when you're eliminating
that really huge burden,
you have to consider the
positive aspect of that burden,
and how do you make sure not
to destroy that positive aspect
if it's too important
to a community?
So again, we're in
very gray, realms
where I did not mean
to say, if I did say,
that it's a leisure
activity that's fun.
And everyone would love to carry
65 pounds of wood every day.
And frankly, why aren't
you guys doing it,
because I highly
recommend it, and I've
been starting to do that myself.
Like of course not.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Right.
However, if there is a reality
that women in developing
countries tend to
just live at home,
and they take care of the kid.
And you take care of the fire,
and you take care of your home.
And that's it.
And the only
opportunity you have
to socialize and get a little
sanity time is through work.
And so if you eliminate
that work, hooray.
But if you don't then
build in some other way
to get that sanity
time, then maybe people
won't be willing to take
that work elimination,
depending on the cost benefits.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that
like [INAUDIBLE]
because I feel like that's
how we got where we are today.
We don't [INAUDIBLE] around
65 pounds of water, but we
[INAUDIBLE].
But we do have other
hobbies or have other things
that have occupied that time.
AMY BANZAERT: Well,
the issue is not--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: It doesn't seem to
come up in our reading, so.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It didn't come to the readings.
So there is no
reading, and there
is no person who's the expert
on all of this infinitely
and can give you every insight.
That's why I'm going to give
you a range of readings,
and you're going to
hear my perspective.
But I'm also giving
your readings,
so it's not just my perspective.
The issue is not ensuring
leisure time necessarily.
That's not what
I'm trying to say.
What I'm trying to
say is that if there's
something about this
activity, that it's
a really sucky
activity, but there's
this really important
aspect to it
that people really value,
if you provide them
an alternative to that sucky
activity that doesn't address
the part that's important to
them, they may not adopt it,
regardless of how hard you work.
So I don't know if
I mentioned this,
but there's the classic
example of latrines.
And you provide
people with latrines,
and you provide the
community with the latrine,
and they never use it.
[INAUDIBLE] They use
it for a chicken coop.
They use it to store grain.
They use it for this.
They use it for that.
But they don't use it
for the actual purpose
that a latrine serves.
And it blows people's minds.
I installed this latrine.
You guys helped me.
We did it all right.
And why aren't you using it?
And it's usually
something subtle
like the latrine is
the only place where
there's a door that locks, and
that's the only secure place.
And it's more important for
me to have a secure place
than it is for me to
have a hygienic place.
And so therefore, I'm not
going to use the latrine
for the intended purpose.
So there's all these unintended
consequences of any technology
that you deliver, and
you have to really think
about those unintended
consequences,
or unanticipated
consequences, if you're
going to deliver
something that's actually
going to be used in the way that
you are hoping it will be used.
Does that help provide
clarity to that subtlety?
Yeah.
So it's really hard to
wrap your head around this,
because there's no--
there's an infinite
number of examples,
but it's hard to make a really
clean, generalized statement,
because it's all subtle.
One thing I thought was
interesting about the energy
outlook was the
Energy Access Index,
and how they rated everything,
and whether that's actually
the right way to
approach things.
It's really useful to
have an access index
and to be able to compare
where people are at,
but are these different
steps on each level
actually the right steps?
And that's open to debate.
I'm not asking for a
yes, it is; no, it's not.
I don't know myself.
But it is interesting.
Do you actually prefer
having low-voltage DC access
that you control to a
240-volt connection that's
poor quality and intermittent?
I'd probably prefer step
three than step four.
So I think it is an
interesting thing
to read these
documents critically,
that even though this is
like practical action,
and they're an amazing group,
and they're really thoughtful
and love their work, this
is still real, hard stuff.
And so it can be subtle.
Were there any other
thoughts people noticed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
see more comparisons.
When it was talking about
the [INAUDIBLE] victims,
I wanted to know
what that number was
for the [? States ?]
[INAUDIBLE] I know.
And I was like, well, yes,
60% of people, [INAUDIBLE]..
And I'm like, well, I feel
like that's actualluy, I mean,
[INAUDIBLE] cooking, because
how else do we really
burn ourselves?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Didn't have much
to help me [INAUDIBLE]
the numbers.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, yeah.
And yeah, and some
other subtleties
are how easy is it for
you to get medical care,
and what are the
implications for you
if you incapacitate
your hand versus if you
rely on your hands to feed
your family every day?
So there's other
subtleties that are
hard to see from just
a 60% number and even
comparing to the US.
But I will also try to
post some resources that
allow you to compare countries
really easily, so that you can,
if the documentation
doesn't provide it,
you can pretty easily look up
on your own, the comparison
if that's of interest.
OK.
So we're fast approaching
the end of the class.
So this week, the primary
homework assignment
is what we call the Personal
Energy Consumption Challenge.
You may or may not know
that in D-Lab development,
students have to spend
a week on $2 a day.
And it's challenging,
and it's really helpful.
And so we were
like, great, we're
going to make a similar
energy assignment,
but it's much more complicated
to limit your energy than it
is to limit your food,
your financial spending.
Obviously, for some of the
reasons we just talked about,
that you can't just
walk into a classroom
and be like, I'm
sorry, professor,
you need to turn
off that projector,
and I need the lights
off and the heat off.
And I can't do my
problem sets today,
because I can't use light,
and I can't use my computer,
because my other
class said that.
We don't actually want you
to fail for a given week
or make everyone in
your world hate you,
because you're restricting.
It's much easier to control
your personal spending
than your personal energy.
So the way we did
this is we split it up
into a few things--
and the other thing
is that most people have a
budget or a general sense
of how much you're spending on
a given day or a given week.
And very few of us as
we just figured out
have a sense of how much
energy we're spending,
consuming on a
given day or week.
So what I would like you to do
is choose two days this week.
And on the first
day, actually spend
your day documenting
at all times,
I'm using my laptop
for this much time.
I'm in a lit room
I'm in a heated room
for this much time.
I'm driving my car for this much
time, all this stuff, and run
through the numbers, so that you
can get a more refined number
than your initial estimate.
I don't want you to spend
1,000 hours on this assignment.
So it would be very easy
to get so anal that you
would have to spend a
ridiculous number of hours
on this assignment.
And so you need to balance
how refined your number is
versus you have a life,
and you can't only
spend it on my class, as
much as I think you should.
So yeah, so take
that into account.
One student last
year I think spent
like 80 hours on
this assignment,
and I really don't want that.
So yeah, and then some of the
things you should think about
is what is in your control, and
what is not in your control,
and what's sort of
in your control?
And then on the second
day, and if it's possible,
and I know there's,
within reason, if you
can make the two days similar.
So if one day is a
weekend, and your weekends
are totally different
from your weekdays,
if you can try not to
do that, so that you
can have a comparison
that's vaguely legitimate.
Try to implement cut-backs
as much as possible
to cut back significantly.
Last year, one student cut
back by taking shorter showers.
That was the entire
cut that they made,
and that's insufficient.
So try to really make it hurt.
Like it hurts to spend
$2 a day for a week.
But at the same time, try
not to fail your classes.
So there's a
balancing act there.
And then document how
hard was it to cut back?
Where could you cut back?
What was out of your control?
And then think about,
but you don't actually
have to experience,
because it would
be very challenging and
prohibitive, is what if I said,
you have to use
10% of the energy
that you're currently using?
What would you do if that
was just a mandatory thing?
How would you live?
And then run through that
as a thought experiment,
but you don't actually
have to do it,
because it would be challenging.
And the reason for the 10% is
looking at the energy usage
in the US versus in Nicaragua.
And then the other assignments
I just want to remind you of.
One is any plastic bottle from
a personal water bottle or Coke
bottle to a 2-liter bottle
we need for a lab coming up
in a few weeks.
So if you can look around your
leaving group and collect a few
and bring them in, that will
make our lives a lot easier
soon.
And then the other
thing is just a reminder
that you should be practicing
un poco espanol, por favor.
So please, do.
Any questions on this homework?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's more
on the plastic bottles.
Is there a place for us to
store the plastic bottles
intermittently?
For example, like
that way, we don't
have to bring in a whole
bunch load of plastic bottles,
if we have them and bring
them in week by week?
AMY BANZAERT: You can
bring them in every week,
and we'll collect them and find
a place in here, in the room
next door to store them.
AUDIENCE: How many do you want?
AMY BANZAERT: We don't
actually need that many,
but it's nice to
have an assortment,
so when you're building
your wind turbine,
you can select the one that
looks most appealing to you.
So we don't need
an infinite-- so
if everyone brought one or
two, that would be plenty.
But some people, it may
be easier than others
to bring them in.
So don't bring in 100, but if
you can bring in four, great.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
OK.
So if you can fill out your
Muddy Cards real quick,
that would be great.
Next lab is Energy Storage
here, and next class
is Lighting and
Community Partner Intro.